Seção 8 de Dom Casmurro.
Esta é uma gravação LibriVox. Todas as gravações LibriVox estão em domínio público. Para mais informações, ou para ser um voluntário, por favor visite: librivox.org.
Gravado por Rachel Moraes.
Dom Casmurro, de Joaquim Maria Machado de Assis.
Capítulos XXXVI a XL.
Capítulo XXXVI Ideia sem Pernas e Ideia sem Braços
Deixei-os, a pretexto de brincar, e fui-me outra vez a pensar na aventura da manhã. Era o que melhor podia fazer, sem latim, e até com latim. Ao cabo de cinco minutos, lembrou-me ir correndo à casa vizinha, agarrar Capitu, desfazer-lhe as tranças, refazê-las e concluí-las daquela maneira particular, boca sobre boca.
É isto, vamos, é isto... Ideia só! ideia sem pernas! As outras pernas não queriam correr nem andar. Muito depois é que saíram vagarosamente e levaram-me à casa de Capitu.
Quando ali cheguei, dei com ela na sala, na mesma sala, sentada na marquesa, almofada no regaço, cosendo em paz. Não me olhou de rosto, mas a furto e a medo, ou, se preferes a fraseologia do agregado, oblíqua e dissimulada. As mãos pararam, depois de encravada a agulha no pano. Eu, do lado oposto da mesa, não sabia que fizesse; e outra vez me fugiram as palavras que trazia.
Assim gastamos alguns minutos compridos, até que ela deixou inteiramente a costura, ergueu-se e esperou-me. Fui ter com ela, e perguntei se a mãe havia dito alguma coisa; respondeu-me que não. A boca com que respondeu era tal que cuido haver-me provocado um gesto de aproximação. Certo é que Capitu recuou um pouco.
Era ocasião de pegá-la, puxá-la, beijá-la... Ideia só! ideia sem braços! Os meus ficaram caídos e mortos. Não conhecia nada da Escritura. Se conhecesse, é provável que o espírito de Satanás me fizesse dar à língua mística do Cântico um sentido direto e natural. Então obedeceria ao primeiro versículo: “Aplique ele os lábios, dando-me o ósculo da sua boca.” E pelo que respeita aos braços, que tinha inertes, bastaria cumprir o vers. 6.º do cap. II: “A sua mão esquerda se pôs já debaixo da minha cabeça, e a sua mão direita me abraçará depois.”
Vedes aí a cronologia dos gestos. Era só executá-la; mas ainda que eu conhecesse o texto, as atitudes de Capitu eram agora tão retraídas, que não sei se não continuaria parado. Foi ela, entretanto, que me tirou daquela situação.
Capítulo XXXVII A Alma é Cheia de Mistérios
— Padre Cabral estava esperando há muito tempo?
— Hoje não dei lição; tive férias.
Expliquei-lhe o motivo das férias. Contei-lhe também que o Padre Cabral falara da minha entrada no seminário, apoiando a resolução de minha mãe, e disse dele coisas feias e duras. Capitu refletiu algum tempo, e acabou perguntando-me se podia ir cumprimentar o padre, à tarde, em minha casa.
— Pode, mas para quê?
— Papai naturalmente há de querer ir também, mas é melhor que ele vá à casa do padre, é mais bonito. Eu não, que já sou meia moça, concluiu rindo.
O riso animou-me. As palavras pareciam ser uma troça consigo mesma, uma vez que, desde manhã, era mulher, como eu era homem. Achei-lhe graça e, para dizer tudo, quis provar-lhe que era moça inteira. Peguei-lhe levemente na mão direita, depois na esquerda, e fiquei assim pasmado e trêmulo. Era a ideia com mãos. Quis puxar as de Capitu, para obrigá-la a vir atrás delas, mas ainda agora a ação não respondeu à intenção.
Contudo, achei-me forte e atrevido. Não imitava ninguém; não vivia com rapazes, que me ensinassem anedotas de amor. Não conhecia a violação de Lucrécia. Dos romanos apenas sabia que falavam pela artinha do Padre Pereira e eram patrícios de Pôncio Pilatos.
Não nego que o final do penteado da manhã era um grande passo no caminho da movimentação amorosa, mas o gesto de então foi justamente o contrário deste. De manhã, ela derreou a cabeça, agora fugia-me; nem é só nisso que os lances diferiam; em outro ponto, parecendo haver repetição, houve contraste.
Penso que ameacei puxá-la a mim. Não juro, começava a estar tão alvoroçado, que não pude ter toda a consciência dos meus atos; mas concluo que sim, porque ela recuou e quis tirar as mãos das minhas; depois, talvez por não poder recuar mais, colocou um dos pés adiante e o outro atrás, e fugiu com o busto. Foi este gesto que me obrigou a reter-lhe as mãos com força.
O busto afinal cansou e cedeu, mas a cabeça não quis ceder também, e caída para trás, inutilizava todos os meus esforços, porque eu já fazia esforços, leitor amigo. Não conhecendo a lição do Cântico, não me acudiu estender a mão esquerda por baixo da cabeça dela; demais, este gesto supõe um acordo de vontades, e Capitu, que me resistia agora, aproveitaria o gesto para arrancar-se à outra mão e fugir-me inteiramente.
Ficamos naquela luta, sem estrépito, porque apesar do ataque e da defesa, não perdíamos a cautela necessária para não sermos ouvidos lá de dentro; a alma é cheia de mistérios. Agora sei que a puxava; a cabeça continuou a recuar; até que cansou; mas então foi a vez da boca. A boca de Capitu iniciou um movimento inverso, relativamente à minha, indo para um lado, quando eu a buscava do outro oposto.
Naquele desencontro estivemos, sem que ousasse um pouco mais, e bastaria um pouco mais...
Nisto ouvimos bater à porta e falar no corredor. Era o pai de Capitu, que voltava da repartição um pouco mais cedo, como usava às vezes.
— Abre, Nanata! Capitu, abre!
Aparentemente era o mesmo lance da manhã, quando a mãe deu conosco, mas só aparentemente; em verdade, era outro. Considerai que de manhã tudo estava acabado, e o passo de D. Fortunata foi um aviso para que nos compuséssemos. Agora lutávamos com as mãos presas, e nada estava sequer começado.
Ouvimos o ferrolho da porta que dava para o corredor interno; era a mãe que abria. Eu, uma vez que confesso tudo, digo aqui que não tive tempo de soltar as mãos da minha amiga; pensei nisso, cheguei a tentá-lo, mas Capitu, antes que o pai acabasse de entrar, fez um gesto inesperado, pousou a boca na minha boca, e deu de vontade o que estava a recusar à força. Repito, a alma é cheia de mistérios.
Capítulo XXXVIII Que Susto, Meu Deus!
Quando Pádua, vindo pelo interior, entrou na sala de visitas, Capitu, em pé, de costas para mim, inclinada sobre a costura, como a recolhê-la, perguntava em voz alta:
— Mas, Bentinho, que é protonotário apostólico?
— Ora, vivam! exclamou o pai.
— Que susto, meu Deus!
Agora é que o lance é o mesmo; mas se conto aqui, tais quais, os dois lances de há quarenta anos, é para mostrar que Capitu não se dominava só em presença da mãe; o pai não lhe meteu mais medo. No meio de uma situação que me atava a língua, usava da palavra com a maior ingenuidade deste mundo. A minha persuasão é que o coração não lhe batia mais nem menos. Alegou susto, e deu à cara um ar meio enfiado; mas eu, que sabia tudo, vi que era mentira e fiquei com inveja.
Foi logo falar ao pai, que apertou a minha mão, e quis saber por que a filha falava em protonotário apostólico. Capitu repetiu-lhe o que ouvira de mim, e opinou logo que o pai devia ir cumprimentar o padre em casa dele; ela iria à minha. E coligindo os petrechos da costura, enfiou pelo corredor, bradando infantilmente:
— Mamãe, jantar, papai chegou!
Capítulo XXXIX A Vocação
Padre Cabral estava naquela primeira hora das honras em que as mínimas congratulações valem por odes. Tempo chega em que os dignificados recebem os louvores como um tributo usual, cara morta, sem agradecimentos. O alvoroço da primeira hora é melhor; esse estado de alma que vê na inclinação do arbusto, tocado do vento, um parabém da flora universal, traz sensações mais íntimas e finas que qualquer outro. Cabral ouviu as palavras de Capitu com infinito prazer.
— Obrigado, Capitu, muito obrigado; estimo que você goste também. Papai está bom? E mamãe? A você não se pergunta; essa cara é mesmo de quem vende saúde. E como vamos de rezas?
A todas as perguntas, Capitu ia respondendo prontamente e bem. Trazia um vestidinho melhor e os sapatos de sair. Não entrou com a familiaridade do costume, deteve-se um instante à porta da sala, antes de ir beijar a mão a minha mãe e ao padre. Como desse a este, duas vezes em cinco minutos, o título de protonotário, José Dias, para se desforrar da concorrência, fez um pequeno discurso em honra “ao coração paternal e augustíssimo de Pio IX”.
— Você é um grande prosa, disse tio Cosme, quando ele acabou.
José Dias sorriu sem vexame. Padre Cabral confirmou os louvores do agregado, sem os seus superlativos; ao que este acrescentou que o Cardeal Mastai evidentemente fora talhado para a tiara desde o princípio dos tempos. E, piscando-me o olho, concluiu:
— A vocação é tudo. O estado eclesiástico é perfeitíssimo, contanto que o sacerdote venha já destinado do berço. Não havendo vocação, falo de vocação sincera e real, um jovem pode muito bem estudar as letras humanas, que também são úteis e honradas.
Padre Cabral retorquia:
— A vocação é muito, mas o poder de Deus é soberano. Um homem pode não ter gosto à igreja e até persegui-la, e um dia a voz de Deus lhe fala, e ele sai apóstolo; veja São Paulo.
— Não contesto, mas o que eu digo é outra coisa. O que eu digo é que se pode muito bem servir a Deus sem ser padre, cá fora; pode-se ou não se pode?
— Pode-se.
— Pois então! exclamou José Dias triunfalmente, olhando em volta de si. Sem vocação é que não há bom padre, e em qualquer profissão liberal se serve a Deus, como todos devemos.
— Perfeitamente, mas vocação não é só do berço que se traz.
— Homem, é a melhor.
— Um moço sem gosto nenhum à vida eclesiástica pode acabar por ser muito bom padre; tudo é que Deus o determine. Não me quero dar por modelo, mas aqui estou eu que nasci com a vocação da Medicina; meu padrinho, que era coadjutor de Santa Rita, teimou com meu pai para que me metesse no seminário; meu pai cedeu. Pois, senhor, tomei tal gosto aos estudos e à companhia dos padres, que acabei ordenando-me. Mas, suponha que não acontecia assim, e que eu não mudava de vocação, o que é que acontecia? Tinha estudado no seminário algumas matérias que é bom saber, e são sempre melhor ensinadas naquelas casas.
Prima Justina interveio:
— Como? Então pode-se entrar para o seminário e não sair padre?
Padre Cabral respondeu que sim, que se podia, e, voltando-se para mim, falou da minha vocação, que era manifesta; os meus brinquedos foram sempre de igreja, e eu adorava os ofícios divinos. A prova não provava; todas as crianças do meu tempo eram devotas. Cabral acrescentou que o reitor de São José, a quem contara ultimamente a promessa de minha mãe, tinha o meu nascimento por milagre; ele era da mesma opinião.
Capitu, cosida às saias de minha mãe, não atendia aos olhos ansiosos que eu lhe mandava; também não parecia escutar a conversação sobre o seminário e suas consequências, e, aliás, decorou o principal, como vim a saber depois. Duas vezes fui à janela, esperando que ela fosse também, e ficássemos à vontade, sozinhos, até acabar o mundo, se acabasse, mas Capitu não me apareceu. Não deixou minha mãe, senão para ir embora. Eram ave-marias, despediu-se.
— Vai com ela, Bentinho, disse minha mãe.
— Não precisa, não, D. Glória, acudiu ela rindo, eu sei o caminho. Adeus, Sr. protonotário...
— Adeus, Capitu.
Tendo dado um passo no sentido de atravessar a sala, é claro que o meu dever, o meu gosto, todos os impulsos da idade e da ocasião eram atravessá-la de todo, seguir a vizinha corredor fora, descer à chácara, entrar no quintal, dar-lhe terceiro beijo, e despedir-me. Não me importou a recusa, que cuidei simulada, e enfiei pelo corredor; mas, Capitu que ia depressa, estacou e fez-me sinal que voltasse. Não obedeci; cheguei-me a ela.
— Não venha, não; amanhã falaremos.
— Mas eu queria dizer a você...
— Amanhã.
— Escuta!
— Fica!
Falava baixinho; pegou-me na mão, e pôs o dedo na boca. Uma preta, que veio de dentro acender o lampião do corredor, vendo-nos naquela atitude, quase às escuras, riu de simpatia e murmurou em tom que ouvíssemos alguma coisa que não entendi bem nem mal. Capitu segredou-me que a escrava desconfiara, e ia talvez contar às outras. Novamente me intimou que ficasse, e retirou-se; eu deixei-me estar parado, pregado, agarrado ao chão.
Capítulo XL Uma Égua
Ficando só, refleti algum tempo, e tive uma fantasia. Já conheceis as minhas fantasias. Contei-vos a da visita imperial; disse-vos a desta casa do Engenho Novo, reproduzindo a de Matacavalos... A imaginação foi a companheira de toda a minha existência, viva, rápida, inquieta, alguma vez tímida e amiga de empacar, as mais delas capaz de engolir campanhas e campanhas, correndo.
Creio haver lido em Tácito que as éguas iberas concebiam pelo vento; se não foi nele, foi noutro autor antigo, que entendeu guardar essa crendice nos seus livros. Neste particular, a minha imaginação era uma grande égua ibera; a menor brisa lhe dava um potro, que saía logo cavalo de Alexandre; mas deixemos metáforas atrevidas e impróprias dos meus quinze anos. Digamos o caso simplesmente.
A fantasia daquela hora foi confessar a minha mãe os meus amores para lhe dizer que não tinha vocação eclesiástica. A conversa sobre vocação tornava-me agora toda inteira, e, ao passo que me assustava, abria-me uma porta de saída.
“Sim, é isto, pensei; vou dizer a mamãe que não tenho vocação, e confesso o nosso namoro; se ela duvidar, conto-lhe o que se passou outro dia, o penteado e o resto...”
Fim da seção 8.
Gravado por Rachel Moraes.